[Musik]
es ist ein eingefrorener Konflikt zwei
Jahre schon halten die Ukrainer den
Krieg
aus whren sich mit Kräften mehr als
gedacht und sicher länger als von Putin
geplant doch der Krieg wird
wintermüde auf beiden Seiten der
abnutzungskrieg hinterlässt
Spuren in Kiev protestierte diese Woche
eine Gruppe Frauen mit ihren Kindern sie
Begrenzung des Wehrdienstes für ihre
Väter und Ehemänner von denen manche
schon seit Kriegsbeginn an der Front
sind auch der Oberkommandierende der
Ukraine Valeri saluschni gibt nun zu der
Krieg steckt in einer Sackgasse ein
Eingeständnis und ein Appell ist die
Zeit reif für
Friedensverhandlungen wohl kein anderer
dürfte das in der Ukraine sagen denn
Präsident selenski versucht weiterhin
unermütlich mit Auszeichnungen und
durchhalterappellen die Moral seines
Landes hochzuhalten Schwäche zu zeigen
würde Russland eine offene Flanke
bieten auch Putin wird nicht nachgeben
111 Milliarden Euro an Militärausgaben
hat er für 2024 eingeplant zwei Drittel
des Staatshaushaltes reserviert für den
russischen Angriffskrieg in der
Ukraine welche Chancen bestehen da noch
für
Frieden
in seinem Buch über Kriege und wie man
sie beendet hat sich Jörn Leonard mit
dieser Frage aus historischer Sicht
beschäftigt schnell merkt man bei der
Lektüre wie einfach Kriege zu entfesseln
sind und wie lange so ein
Friedensprozess dauert die Natur des
Krieges bestimmt sein
Ende dem 30jährigen Krieg fielen
zwischen 4 und 10 Millionen Menschen zum
Opfer fast ein Drittel Mitteleuropas 30
Jahre Krieg und allein die
Friedensverhandlungen dauerten D
[Musik]
Jahre wer noch Chancen auf dem
Schlachtfeld sieht wird den Kampf
fortsetzen solange es
geht der erste Weltkrieg endete erst als
die Erschöpfung einer Kriegspartei so
weit ging dass die Fortsetzung des
Konflikts keinen Sinn mehr
hatte verfügbare Ressourcen bestimmen
den Kippmoment von Kriegen aber nicht
unbedingt die Einsicht der Akte
wem die militärischen Mittel ausgehen
der muss aufhören zu kämpfen genau das
tat das nationalsozialistische Dritte
Reich nicht bis zum
Untergang ein fauler frieden kann den
Krieg
verlängern Rom gegen katago die
Friedensbedingungen nach dem zweiten
poischen Krieg waren drakonisch kartargo
durfte ohne Einwilligung Roms gar nichts
und Rom nutzte den erstbesten Vorwand
katago komplett
[Musik]
auszulöschen der Weg zum Frieden ist
lang es ist ein Weg der kleinen Schritte
erst waffenpausen dann Waffenstillstand
dann Deeskalation und internationale
Vermittlung sicher auch in der
Ukraine in Kiev wurde diese Woche der
Weihnachtsbaum aufgestellt ein Symbol
der Hoffnung auf Frieden in Zeiten des
[Musik]
Krieges wir wollen mehr Wissen darüber
wie man Kriege beendet deshalb spreche
ich nun live mit dem Historiker Jörn
leonhard Professor an der Albert Ludwigs
Universität Freiburg guten Abend und
erstmal herzlichen Glückwunsch zum
gottfried Wilhelm leibnitzpreis den sie
wie heute bekannt wurde bekommen die
höchste Auszeichnung für
Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler
in
Deutschland
ganz herzlichen Dank Frau schotmann Herr
Leon hart blicken wir als erstes auf die
Ukraine dort scheint es gerade für beide
Seiten weder vor noch zurückzugehen ist
das nun der richtige Zeitpunkt für
Verhandlungen ich glaube das ehrlich
gesagt mit Blick auf historische
Beispiele nicht weil beide Seiten und
das erfahren wir ja praktisch jeden Tag
noch glauben dass sie auf dem
Schlachtfeld Gewinne generieren können
Gewinne erzielen können und der
Augenblick in dem ein Krieg sozusagen
reif wird für den Frieden der ist eben
erst erreicht wenn beide Seiten von
einer Fortsetzung der militärischen
Gewalt nichts mehr erwarten können dann
kann die Diplomatie das zeigen ganz
viele historische Beispiele tätig werden
dann kann man mit Vermittlung beginnen
mit Internationalisierung aber dieser
Moment ist noch nicht gekommen weder für
für die Ukraine noch für Russland aber
sie sagen wenn sie nichts mehr erwarten
können ich meine die Kriegsmüdigkeit die
ist eindeutig in der Ukraine zeichnet
sich ab wir haben gerade gesehen Frauen
Mütter demonstrieren dass ihre Männer
nicht mehr im Krieg bleiben das müsste
doch Konsequenzen
haben das stimmt aber es ist ja völlig
klar dass ein Aggressor wie Wladimir
Putin genau auf diese Form der
Erschöpfung spekuliert wie auch auf das
enger werdende Zeitfenster für den
Westen die abnehmende resilienzfähigkeit
der westlichen Demokratie und das
Entscheidende ist eben dass nicht eine
Seite sondern beide Seiten diesen Reife
Moment erreicht haben müssen und Putin
das sehen wir ja in der Mobilisierung
der Kriegswirtschaft wir sehen es an
seiner internationalen Aufwertung die im
Augenblick passiert Putin sieht dass er
die Ukraine vielleicht doch noch dahin
bringen kann wohin er sie haben wollte
als er mit diesem imperialen
Angriffskrieg begonnen hat es müssen
eben beide Seiten das Gefühl haben dass
sie von einem rationalen Frieden mehr
erwarten können als von der Fortsetzung
militärischer Gewalt und der Augenblick
ist eben noch nicht gekommen der Westen
hat immer seine überzeugungkund getan
dass er den die Ukraine so lange
unterstützen muss und will bis sie eben
diesen Krieg ganz gewin ist mit so einer
Einstellung quasi von sei beiden Seiten
überhaupt Frieden zu
machen
das ist der große das ist die große
Hürde das ist das große Problem sie
haben es ja in dem Vorspann auch gesagt
ähm die Wege in den Frieden sind wenn
wir auf historische Beispiele in der
Neuzeit blicken eigentlich immer
langfristige gewesen die wenigsten
Kriege sind kurze Kriege und wenn sie
lang sind dann haben wir häufig das
Phänomen das Kriege sich auch um die
Zahl der Opfer verlängern weil man eben
nur glaubt mit einem Sieg politisch den
Frieden zu überleben ähm wenn selenski
jetzt sagen würde wir machen
Konzessionen dann würde er eben auch
innen poliolitisch unter enormen Druck
geraten und in Russland hat sich ja in
der prigoschin Episode gezeigt dass
irgendwann eben auch die Legitimation in
Kriegen sehr fragil werden kann diese
Faktoren tragen eigentlich noch dazu bei
dass ähm der Frieden schwer zu erreichen
sein wird und dann sprechen wir noch
nicht von einem weiteren wichtigen
Faktor nämlich der Abwesenheit von
internationalen Vermittlern der
Internationalisierung die in diesem
Konflikt denken Sie an China und
Russland eben im Augenblick dazu
beiträgt dass der Krieg erstmal
weitergeht und ich glaube wir müssen
nüchtern auf diesen Konflikt blicken und
dazu können können aus meiner Sicht eben
auch historische Beispiele durchaus
beitragen eben helfen denn bei diesem
nüchternen Blick die historischen
Beispiel oder anders gefragt welcher
Blick in die Historie könnte uns hen en
und vielleicht sogar etwas Optimismus
Spenden dass dieser Krieg dann doch bei
aller verfahrenheit ein Ende
nimmt historisch kann man erstmal sagen
ganz banal dass alle Kriege irgendwann
enden das galt eben auch für den
30-jährigen Krieg oder für einen
entsetzlichen Krieg wie den Ersten
Weltkrieg oder den Zweiten Weltkrieg
aber zur historischen Erkenntnis gehört
eben auch so würde ich es formulieren
die Warnung vor einem faulen Frieden
macht eine Seite Konzessionen denken Sie
an die 30er Jahre in der Vorbereitung
des Zweiten Weltkriegs der Alliierten
gegenüber Hitler macht eine Seite
Konzessionen kann das den Aggressor im
Grunde genommen darin bestätigen dass er
auf einem guten Weg ist und ich bin
sicher dass jemand wie Putin der zum
Krieg entschlossen ist ganz genau darauf
sieht wie der Westen im Augenblick seine
resiliensfähigkeit seine
Verteidigungsfähigkeit verliert er wird
mit der mit dem Zeitfaktor Arbeiten er
wird abwarten was in Amerika bei den
Wahlen passiert und deshalb ist das im
Augenblick für die Ukraine eine so
schwierige Situation die Warnung vor
einem faulen Frieden ist glaube ich das
was wir in vielen ähm
kriegskonstellationen insbesondere des
20 Jahrhunderts erkennen können das ist
eine sehr nüchterne Bestandsaufnahme
aber ich glaube diese Nüchternheit die
ist vielleicht das was uns der zweite
Blick ähm in die Geschichte häufig
bringt ein Herr raustreten aus der
Tagesaktualität und auch mit diesem Ziel
mit dieser Motivation habe ich dieses
Buch
geschrieben